36 Jahre sein gesamtes Arbeitsleben war
Peter Gommel für den Versandhändler
Klingel aus pforzeheim tätig jetzt steht
er vor dem Nichts denn Klingel ist
insolvent ausgerechnet im hundersten
Unternehmensjahr das ist so wie wenn
innerlich eine Bombe explodiert also es
war früher waren es immer die anderen
denen es passiert ist und wir waren die
sichere Bank wir waren lange Zeit
rentabel wir waren effektiv effizient
und produktiv und plötzlich kommt sowas
auf un zu das ist Wahnsinn so wie die
Titan kann ich sinken und Klingel kann
ich bleide gehen doch es kam anders und
so verlieren 1300 Beschäftigte nicht nur
ihren
Arbeitsplatz wir waren ein verdammt
gutes Team muss ich dazu sagen es ist
eine Art Familie gewesen und es ist
immer noch Familie und wenn jeden Tag
jetzt 30 40 Leute wieder weggehen jetzt
dann ist es ein Einschnitt das ist so
wie wenn Famil Mitglied geht bis zuletzt
habe man versucht Klingel zu retten und
einen Investor für die Firmengruppe zu
finden beteuert der
sanierungsgeschäftsführer doch die Liste
an Problemen sei einfach zu lang das
Unternehmen nicht mehr rentabel zum
einen war es die it-umstellung die
eingeführt worden ist im zweiten Quartal
dritten Quartal
2022 darüber hinaus natürlich die
Konsumzurückhaltung aufgrund des
ukrainekriegs der gestiegenen
Energiekosten
und der hohen Inflation dennoch das
firmenende hätte man abwenden können
kritisiert die Gewerkschaft werdi und
befürchtet durch das Ende von Klingel
weitreichende Folgen für den Standard
vorzim ist natürlich sehr dramatisch
durch die Schließung von Galeria hat man
eben schon viele Arbeitsplätze die
weggefallen sind oder wegfallen werden
und jetzt mit Klingel ist es einfach so
eine große Zahl dass das inner auch ein
großen Stadt wie forzheim nicht einfach
abgefangen werden kann in letzten 10
Jahren sank Deutschland weit die Zahl
der
Unternehmensinsolvenzen im letzten Jahr
dann die Trendwende und in diesem Jahr
der sprunghaft der Anstieg ein Plus von
23,5%. eine Normalisierung auf sehr
niedrigem Niveau so Ökonomin Hottenrott
kein Grund zur
Panik historisch gesehen sind die Zahlen
aber noch im Rahmen also wir hatten
ungefähr
18100 Insolvenzen dieses Jahr im Jahr
2014 waren es fast 25000 also wir sind
historisch gesehen nicht auf einem
Höchststand aber wir sehen tatsächlich
einen Anstieg der Insolvenzen von
größeren Mittelständlern und das ist
natürlich eine Bewegung
die möglicherweise besorgniserregend ist
größere Mittelständler die Straucheln
dazu zählt auch die superbiomarkt AG aus
Münster die Einzelhandelskette geriet
schon 2022 in Schwierigkeiten konnte
sich aber in Eigenverwaltung sanieren
auch hier war die Liste an Problemen
lang höhere Mieten höhere Einkaufspreise
mehr Kosten die das Unternehmen nicht an
die Kunden weitergeben
konnte bei uns waren die Strompreise
exorbitant gestiegen ein
arbeitspreissteigerung von 4,7 Cent auf
42 Cent bei 6 Kil 6 Millionen
Kilowattstunden das war einfach
gigantisch neben dem Handel und dem
Baugewerbe verzeichnet vor allem das
verarbeitende Gewerbe einen Anstieg an
filmenpiten ein Plus von 30%. das ist
gerade fast alle Branchen trifft habe
viele Gründe erklärt Patrick Ludwig
Hansch und spricht von einem
coronaabomerang ja wir haben ganz viele
Unternehmen die sind schon angeschlagen
die sind durch die coronazeit gekommen
sind mit der Hilfe des Staates und mit
den Hilfsmaßnahmen über Wasser geblieben
und jetzt sind die Krisen aber so massiv
von Inflation über Zinsen bis hin zu
hohen Energiepreisen und auch ein
allgemeinen Unsicherheit die die
Unternehmer haben dass viele jetzt
einfach nicht mehr können und sagen es
geht nicht mehr auch für viele gr Namen
ging es dieses Jahr nicht mehr weiter
z.B Peak und Kloppenburg oder zuletzt
der Projektentwickler signner dessen
Insolvenz gerade in Form brachliegender
Baustellen wie hier in Düsseldorf oder
Hamburg sichtbar wird experten rechnen
auch im kommenden Jahr mit einem
weiteren Anstieg der
Unternehmensinsolvenzen erwarten aber
nicht zwingend negative Folgen für die
deutsche
Wirtschaft insgesamt können Insolvenzen
natürlich auch eine Chance sein ein
Unternehmen neu aufzustellen in
Verbindung allerdings mit den
Unternehmensschließungen also wo
wirklich die Geschäftstätigkeit
endgültig aufgegeben wird ist es aber
natürlich doch so dass diese Unternehmen
dann erstmal weg sind nicht jedes
Insolvenzverfahren endet aber genau mit
diesem Effekt hier in pzheim ist es
nicht gelungen die Firma Klingel neu
aufzustellen Ende Januar wird der
Geschäftsbetrieb eingestellt für Peter
Gommel bedeutet das nach 36 Jahren einen
neuen Arbeitgeber suchen also ich habe
schon zahlreiche Bewerbungen laufen und
immer wieder zu Vorstellungsgesprächen
aber bis jetzt war
zum Zeitpunkt des heutigen Tages noch
nichts richtiges dabei sein Wunsch
wieder einen Beruf finden der zu ihm
passt